he's Tom Verducci MLB Network insider
Sports Illustrated senior baseball
writer watch Tom on MLB tonight and
today starting at 1:00 eastern part of
MLB network's 14 hours of live trade
deadline coverage today and his latest
column was which teams are facing the
most trade deadline pressure starting
with the Yankees Yankees do anything
today Tom I think they will all be
really surprised if we get to four
o'clock then and they don't have an
addition to this rotation now I can't
tell you who it is I think my best guess
would be Robby ray of Arizona certainly
they're gonna talk to the Mets and have
been about wheeler and syndergaard but
you know there's just too many I think
continuing issues for that rotation it's
not like one or two guys just have a
mini slump here I think there's issues
with that rotation and they need a
little more length a little more
reliability so my guess is it'd be a bad
day for the Yankees if they don't come
out of this with a starting pitcher let
me look at what the Mets did when they
made the trade they you know bring in a
pitcher that most people thought was
headed towards the Yankees but I started
to read some people I have great respect
for Bob Nightingale said it's a
wonderful deal you know you can
stockpile you can trade syndergaard you
can trade wheeler like you can you can
do something I just want to know what
their game plan is because as a fan
that's all I want to know what is our
game plan because it feels like the Mets
are sort of related to the New York
Knicks not quite sure what their game
plan is so you being the all knowing all
telling what are the Mets doing yeah
that's probably a good cop actually to
the next because the Mets don't want to
admit that they need to retool right so
they keep patching things is one reason
why Brody van wagon was hired the Mets
didn't want to hire a general manager
who would give him a diagnosis of hey
you're not good enough to be a
postseason team you need to start
rebuilding now they want to patch this
thing together and start making runs and
keep making runs at wild cards that can
get you in a lot of trouble so they're
continuing that mo now that being said
they did make a really good deal I mean
when you see what the
Indians got for Trevor Bauer that deal
looks even better for the Mets today
than it did a couple of days ago because
there's not a whole lot of difference
between strowman and Bauer but I don't
know what the Mets next play is I'm not
sure that they do but it's not going to
be if they trade syndergaard or wheeler
it's not going to be just fortify the
farm system I think they want major
league ready players back whoever they
trade yeah just trying to and if they've
cornered the market on pitching you know
that's great if that's what their game
plan is and and they're able to keep
these guys and then they do something in
the offseason like the Reds getting
Bauer
why did the Reds go why did they get him
and Houston or something you know the
Yankees somebody else didn't get Bauer
for the stretch run well first of all
with the Mets that if they want to build
not pitching that's fine but they put
one of the worst defenses and baseball
behind them and put the Roman a sinker
ball guys that's what I mean a plan
right is that the plan is a really good
one and as far as the Reds kind of
similar to the Mets in that they should
be breaking this thing down but their
attendance
they've lost almost a million people in
the last three or four years and
baseball in Cincinnati has really been
struggling that's why they took on a lot
of one-year guys this year and that's
why now Bauer is going to go in the
rotation not just for the next two
months but for next year and actually
it's a great rotation when you think
about great Castillo Bauer going into
2020 so that's another team that needs
to make the team attractive I think they
did that necessarily better this year
but it was a more attractive team on the
field what about the Dodgers Dodgers to
me their big play here is trying to get
Felipe Vasquez from the Pittsburgh
Pirates you know the way that Kenley
Jansen is throwing I think they're
concerned the cutter velocity is down
he's throwing it less he's very
susceptible to home runs as he was last
year in the perfect world they want a
lefty for that bullpen anyway but
especially a guy like Vasquez who could
be kinda like coinsurance behind Janssen
ticket on a guy like Vasquez is gonna be
huge you know he did players don't need
to trade him he's under control it's
going to take a really top-flight
prospect think the Aroldis Chapman deal
right with Culebra Torres going to the
Yankees that hasn't been the Dodgers mo
they've done a great job keeping the
right
players whether it was jock Peterson or
Cody Bellinger or some of the younger
guys there but if they can't get Vasquez
they still think they're gonna be in the
market to try to find another
left-handed pitcher it might be Will
Smith of the Giants but they have to
come out of this with another bullpen
arm he's Tom Verducci MLB Network
insider Sports Illustrated senior
baseball writer I thought the Indians
did pretty well last night with their
haul that they got you know in and Puig
you know I know we wanted to make him
bow Jackson he's not gonna be that but
you know he's got respectable numbers
and he's gonna probably be a rental what
do you make of what the Indians did here
I'm with you Dan they did great because
listen hey Bowers the guy who was gonna
make 20 million in arbitration next year
he was not coming back to the Indians so
they were shopping him now or in the
offseason if they didn't like what they
got now and they liked what they got now
I mean this is a team that was 10th in
the league in runs score they definitely
did help offensively and especially on
the corner outfield and they just made
the first trade in history where they
got back to guys they've hit 20 home
runs two guys now it's hard enough
trying to find one of those and they got
two of them in friend mill Reyes and
Puig so yeah no queeg is to me he's
never been the kind of player who's as
good as what the hype is what he's going
to help the India's there's not that
about that alrighty last night with a
bench-clearing brawl
what's the reputation that the Pirates
have well around baseball they
definitely throw more fast balls in than
anybody else right so when you do that
you're going to hit a lot of people and
they do so the reputation is that a lot
of those hit by pitches are done on
purpose there's no question that's the
way the team's look at the Pirates they
don't try to back down from what they do
they want to push people off the plate
so listen when you play in your division
teams 1819 times and it happens that
much and this is what happened with the
Reds you're going to have some hard
feelings you're gonna have some issues
that bubble up even before the game is
played and last night it just exploded
yeah but the Pirates are in last place
is this strategy working yeah you could
argue that it's not for that reason but
yeah they're you know what's funny Dan
is that most of baseball now is gone I
don't wanna stay away from fast balls
but fast ball use has actually gone down
a lot in the last four or five years
because fast balls get hits become over
breaking ball game and the Pirates are
still operating throwing two seamers in
right-handed pitchers right headed
hitters so it's not a model that other
teams are copying and I think because
now they do or one of the rare teams
that throws a lot inside it really
stands out hitters aren't used to it I
also you know you look at this situation
here if if baseball wanted to get rid of
this you know hockey is getting rid of
fighting whether they you know they
announce it they are what what would you
do if you're the commissioner and and
I'm okay with you pitching inside I just
don't like this you showboat it on a
home run I have to hit you and now now
you put the pressure on the other teams
pitcher to hit another guy and then when
does it end it just continues to go back
and forth but does the commissioner how
involved does he get into a situation
like this yeah a lot now they're bound a
lot by precedent but I'm with you first
of all I can't stand the whole macho
business that because you did your job
and hit a homerun off me then I have to
hit you the next time up or you you
stood at the plate and watched it a
little too long I can't stand that and
it's only a matter of time before
someone really really get murked on
something stupid like that I say what
you're going to see here is a really
harsh penalty on David Bell the Reds
manager I mean he was already thrown out
of the game so he comes out of the
clubhouse to go on the field and he
makes a beeline for Clint Hurdle and
actually made contact with him when
you're the manager that Major League
Baseball can hold you to a higher
standard than the players right you're
not protected by the Union in terms of
grievances so you have a manager who's
already been ejected comes out of the
clubhouse onto the field and actually
adds to the freitas on the field is not
a peacemaker what's a wall at all he's
accelerating things I'll tell you the
longest suspension I can think of for a
manager for an on-field issue was Billy
Martin got suspended once for a week for
one of his many trades against managers
it wouldn't shock me if David Bell gets
at least a week suspension that's
something I think Major League Baseball
really wants to come down and say we're
holding you to a higher standard than
the players well didn't Pete Rose get
like 20 games for bumping it up
yeah I guess that was the day Paloma
yeah a bad one in Cincinnati yeah that
was that might have been it really hard
physical contact not just bumping at
umpire kind of pushing and shoving him
but again in this case he's already been
thrown out of the game and David Bill
has already been thrown out of more
games that than any manager in Reds
history over the course of a season we
stopped two months left I'll leave you
with this you know the Dodgers by far
and away dominating but you know we
always look at some teams to build for
the regular season some are built for
the postseason
I like having Kershaw as my third
starter in here you've already talked
about the bullpen it feels like you know
is this Groundhog Day again if you know
when they get into the postseason are
they better equipped this year than they
were last year I think they are better
equipped to meet a differences were you
Rio and Buehler but they have you
already beep it's great last year in the
postseason but especially over you you
know Rich Hill we saw every time right
he pitched five innings as soon as the
lineup went around the third time he was
out of the game and the bullpen got a
little bit taxed or overexposed in the
postseason I think this year you're
looking at length at a book Ryu and
Bueller and this kid Julio Reyes now is
I think could be a difference maker out
of the pen yeah if I were to see the
team's right now there's no question in
my mind the Dodgers would be number one
and I'm sure they think that way in
their own mind and they haven't won it
since 88 lost the last two losing the
last game of the year by the same score
in their home ballpark I think anything
short of a World Series championship is
a disappointment for the Dodgers a night
that may be an unfair bar to put on any
team but based on where how good they
are in the last couple of years in this
case I don't think it's unfair second
best player in baseball is who uh well
that's a really good question
you could go Francisco Lindor because he
plays such a premium position so well at
shortstop switch hitter franchise type
of player it's a great question
it just tells you how good Mike Trout is
right that you started with number two
but he's also is it possible he's having
one of his best seasons oh I think he is
because his plate discipline is better
than ever
he may hit 50 home runs he may have a
personal hi at home runs and his defense
has been better too I mean he's good
defensively don't get me wrong but the
amazing thing about Mike Trout is he
started as the best player baseball
probably seven eight years ago and he
does get better every year he's just I
hope people understand you know we're
looking at like a DiMaggio or a mantel
of our generation and I know the fact
that he hasn't been in the postseason
more than once and never won a game kind
of dims that that light but it were
lucky to be watching this guy play in
his prime would you put Yelich or
Bellinger Oh in there it's a great race
for MVP I would right now lean a little
bit more towards Yelich for MVP but
those guys got to be in my top five
again I'm gonna go more middle of the
field then corner Alfio guys talking
about best players of the game I always
lean toward shortstop centerfield but
you can't go wrong with those two guys
they've been so fun to watch all year
Tom have fun today and we'll see at 1:00
Eastern on MLB network's 14 hours of
trade deadline coverage today thank you
Tom you got Tom Verducci the MLB Network
insider Sports Illustrated senior
baseball writer for more Dan Patrick
show tune in the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR Live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]